vers 4 heures du matin ce bus de voyages
dérape sur la route verglacée
il effectue plusieurs tonneaux avant de
finir sa course en contrebas éparpillés
au sol les effets personnels de trente
deux ressortissants portugais
il devait se rendre à fribourg en suisse
mais c'est en saône et loire que leur
voyage s'arrête brutalement
bilan quatre morts 25 blessés et trois
personnes dans un état d'urgence absolue
c'est une perte de contrôle
vraisemblablement dans un endroit qui
était glissant puisque la route est très
verglacées ce matin ensuite sur les
autres circonstances et nous faudra un
peu de temps pour les déterminer
à bord du véhicule deux chauffeurs qui
se relayaient au volant sorti indemne de
l'accident ils seront questionnés par
les enquêteurs mais selon les premières
indications il roulait trop vite à plus
de 90 km heure sur une route réputée
dangereuse et malgré une alerte orange
pour neige et verglas
même si un effort considérable effet
avec plus de 50 millions de travaux qui
sont faits chaque année pour la mise à
deux fois deux voies de la route sandro
amp atlantique
cela ne change rien au fait qu' on doit
toujours veiller à adapter sa vitesse
aux conditions de circulation aux
conditions climatiques et c'était
apparemment pas le cas sur place 90
pompiers et vingt gendarmes sont restés
à pied d'oeuvre pendant plusieurs heures
pour dégager le corps d'une des victimes
bloquées sous la carcasse du véhicule
à la mi journée la circulation a pu
reprendre sur la rcea entièrement
dégagée mais les autorités appellent à
la plus grande vigilance